hello Fandango movie clips with the pass
brothers directors of the biblical
apocalypse film Jerusalem forget you
primed and ready to check out Jerusalem
we're going to give our top 5 favorite
religious horror movies number 5 on our
list is 2009 straight with to help an
old woman curses Christine who must
figure out how to rid herself of the
demons that Hunter directed by Sam Raimi
the mastermind behind the Evil Dead
films and written by his Sam and his
brother Ivan the fourth film on our list
is wreck with a perfect blend of both
style and substance director Jean
Balaguer oh and Paco Plaza set out to
create a classic horror movie but to
tell the story more like a TV show wreck
unfolds in real time and attempts to
immerse the viewer in the experience
through the eyes of a TV reporter and
her cameraman the production is sparse
with an almost custom phobic feel where
something horrifying and unknown is
happening number three is a devil's
advocate we're talking about director
guy Greene's 1977 West German
english-language film not the Keanu
Reeves Al Pacino feel the same name the
devil's advocate tells the story of
Roman Catholic priest the priest is sent
to remote Italian village to play
devil's advocate in the investigation of
a man who is a candidate to be canonized
by the church - we have Roman Polanski's
classic psychological horror film
Rosemary's Baby centering around
rosemary Woodhouse a young housewife who
along with her husband moves into a
fancy pardal building where strange
things began to happen when she wakes
with scratch marks all over her body and
soon received news that she is pregnant
things take a decidedly evil turn which
brings us to number 1 on our list
it's The Exorcist William Friedkin's
1973 masterpiece that was the first
horror film to be nominated for the Best
Picture Academy Award the head-turning
vomit spewing demonically possessed well
the old girl distress potty-mouth is
pretty much hollywood's gold standard
for evil personified and there you have
it our top 5 favorite religious horror
movies and that should be perfect to get
you ready to check out our film
Jerusalem tells the story of two young
American women who travel to Tel Aviv
for a vacation but are persuaded to
change their plans by young
archaeologists and pretty soon all hell
breaks loose and they find themselves in
the middle of a biblical apocalypse
I'm Europe and this is my brother drone
for Fandango movie clips
be sure to check out Jerusalem in
theaters